bella tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono vari j
avete presente quando giudicate la
bellezza di una persona cosa
succederebbe se esistesse un sito in
grado di giudicare la bellezza di una
persona ed è per questo ragazzi che
siamo su un fatto che questo sito e
quando caricate una foto ti dice quanto
sei bello è anche quanto sei vecchio tra
l'altro provando con questa tizia quelli
vent'anni è una donna e mi dice che è
fatto e detto queste ragazzine riprovare
con altre foto ecco chi possiamo
cominciare sono con la bellezza fatta
persona
grazie grave ma basta materiale 21 anni
mi piace preso stanley in griglia sono
pinocchio regolare prima dei ragazzi da
adesso che abbiamo appurato che io sono
gnocco perfetto non potevo provare più
di pare affatto i problemi di pace
quanto possono dare ligneo pezza più di
clive non più di me oh mio dio allora mi
photoshop o la mia faccia sopra quella
di pdf
ecco la barra deve uscire fuori dallo
schermo adesso perché non so non ha
senso la fai ha sì stronzo a voi
contrari e allora photoshop evo più di
pai sulla mia faccia di caz esce fuori
meglio di così questo volevo questo
maledizione ma che figo guardali beni
quest'uomo e considera questa roba è
considerata godlike come un dio
a questo punto quanto è bello dio
proviamo dio dobbiamo vedere dio sul
serio contro cioè ecco perfetto trovato
61 anni ed effetti io e femmina più di
pai e gold live tu dovresti essere più
di file ai caffè nove fermi perciò li
m'illum in azione prima lui prima lui in
assoluto dov'è
eccolo qua come li trova la faccia sul
petto e ha posto dei capelli a rosario
muniz e lì da più di bile ma correrà
così un bel ragazzo perché sei dubbioso
la cina
selena serena
come sporca merda se almeno come
vesciche sei bella quanto me non vedo
perché non dovresti metterti con molti
perché non essere colti pregano essere
cosa ti prego no
sei una stronza lo sapevo che all the
stoning ok megan fox tuning quindi mi
dovrei accontentare di megan fox sempre
il peggio è
cazzo guardi ecco qui mia zlatan mi
chiamò da subito devo provare subito lui
ragazzi lui non è gold live lui c'è come
una casella posta che adesso spunterà
gestito zlatan devi capire ecco due
nessuno bravo come zlatan è anche brad
marketing pensate bene la forza di
vladimir putin gloria dal curiosissimo
ok solo ok ok bombardiamo crane come fa
sapere anche le tasse ci si conosce un
tizio dietro che ogni volta che carichi
la foto scrive quanto secondo lui è
bella una persona e quante e quanti anni
ha
perché non è possibile come fa capirlo
34 anni è certo borat e sturminger ma
corre a questo no questo cazzo
vedi di dare un buon voto perché dio mio
zlatan non puoi raggiungere la bellezza
di platform come caso ti permetto come
fa essere un uomo allora vegas o li
abbiamo due master a confronto in questo
momento della sinistra con tutta la sua
chioma è il suo suo fascino gigi
d'alessio all'angolo destro con ben 250
chili di zappa enrico pasquale pratico
prima di tutto proviamo gigi che non si
scappa la jiji 33 anni ok solo taper
gigi gigi ok ragazzi premiamo enrico
pasquale pratico non solo per curiosità
parti gigi lo batti no cosa perché da
gigi era veda in un pò dei batteri ggg
cia il suo fascino
così caricato alla copertina dell'ultimo
episodio di the forest per vedere che
cosa esce fuori 23 anni perché solo ok
che problemi ci ho guadagnato due anni
in più semplicemente mettendomi il
turbante l'altro porno avete idea di che
la bellezza di questa cosa aspetta che
ci si carichi bello 23 anni offre grazie
altro che zoolander se indosso un
cappello cio 30 anni quindi se metto il
cappello posso andare in discoteca senza
che mi chiedono la carta d'identità dei
ragazzi abbiamo scherzato adesso ora di
fare un test serio stato mai più o meno
ok 22 anni adesso che mi ha detto questa
cosa proviamo a fare perfetto rai a
questi si che sono batida mucciaccio
fatevi mette non è il pizzetto ci sta ma
un pochettino più incazzato tipo così
sono jack sparrow ragazzi bellissimo
perfetto pronto per isis troviamo carica
alla foto a destra dove il cazzo c'è 29
anni
vabbè sono aumentato di 6 anni l'ha
neanche di troppo e pensavo peggio
veni con la scritta pugni in faccia mi
da 24 anni normalmente 1 maturo non si
scrive impegni sulla mezzo alla fronte
giusto che vuoi vedere di capri a quanto
a me prima ragazzi ha dato stunning che
dopo ott
quindi voglio dire quanto da di caprio
soca magari quanti oscar white cuculo
tanto più gnocco io allora ragazzi prova
farvi dare una valutazione per come sono
in questo momento mi faccio la foto e
vediamo almeno otto ti prego so che ne
sono state ok per questo bel ragazzo li
dai quanto gigi operativo ragazzi voglio
fare un esperimento vedere che cosa mi
dice voglio vedere cosa mi dice se
carico lo slider man che non ai
lineamenti e quindi scusa non abbiamo
potuto individuare la faccia ever non
celate la faccio io la faccia lo slider
man neanche a questo sì che l'uomo fammi
vedere di quanto li dai a quest'uomo non
solo per capire 25 anni femmina of
grandissima abbiamo scoperto tutti che
una femmina lo slider me non lo sapevo
io un carattere meraviglioso non si può
dire lo stesso delle rughe però per
carità ma proviamo noi non mi trova la
faccia mi incazzo è perché lui non vanno
discriminati gli zombie 25 anni uomo dai
fanti di voi uscirebbero questo pezzo
dell'orco dite la verità io so che io
quella che ci devono merda so nice per
jennifer lawrence i capi sono molto
meglio il suo sito web ma inizia a
discriminare
le persone c'è solo un attore che non
può discriminare soltanto tagli il voto
giusto non far cacate solo su di conan
techno ragazzi tocqueville episodio
spero che vi sia piaciuto è stato strano
come se come sito è strano prove dovevo
assolutamente farlo perché veramente
troppo figo spero che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi un bel live per chuck norris
altrimenti si potrebbe incazzare è
capace di facebook è un invito stata la
descrizione servizi indiscrezioni ci
picchiavano con servito dai ragazzi